VBS is a condition that's characterized
by pain at the opening of the vagina and
though it may seem uncommon shockingly
VBS may affect up to 15% of women for me
it also involves having to apply nurse
numbing cream to my vagina once a day
your life a jack
both are vestibuli tis syndrome VBS is a
form of old edenia and though the exact
cause is still unknown
it's theorized that perhaps the body's
nerves hormones and immune system plays
a role the pain can come and go but when
present it makes vaginal intercourse
incredibly painful the night I
discovered it there was just a night
that I was trying to have sex and it all
of a sudden put there was a piece of
glass being shoved into me and I'm not
making that up
so much so that I actually tried to look
for something the next thing I know I'm
at the doctor's and I'm explaining to
the guy that I've been dating that I'm
gonna be having these flare-ups
I know unfortunate and many deal with
bigger struggles but still I just
couldn't shake the fear that this sexual
restriction would create a void between
us that we could never fill and neither
could Corey just felt like that we would
always be lacking and the most intimate
ways that we could be I think sometimes
you're just waiting for it to go away
and that's what my entire relationship
earned into we would try to be
physically intimate and it would be like
just give me another week let's give it
another couple days give it you know
just this month you know just this next
month yeah within the first month of us
realizing that this might be something
that we had to deal with at least for me
it snow balled in my head
the point where we broke up turned into
this constant cycle of excuses and then
before I knew it my entire relationship
had fallen apart I felt like I was
completely sexually broken but it was
also at this moment my friends launched
a mission to prove that I wasn't my
friend surprising me with vibrators
awesome non-invasive sexual toys they
for to be meaningful articles and
recommended sex positive literature in
the end all of these things helped
reinforce a more diverse spectrum of
valued intimacy meanwhile Korres views
on sex had been changing too so I
started reading this book and holy [ __ ]
within the first two pages it was
incredible it was meant for me in that
moment it's very unusual I feel like to
hear a man talk about sex and intimacy
in the way that he does in this book I
think my definition of sex was very very
small it really challenged me and
challenged my views and I've been able
to redefine intimacy that's what makes
it a tight relationship that's what
makes sex fun and I lost sight of that
afterwards corey reached out to talk
something that i heard from you a lot
you would say that you felt broken the
intimacy is 50/50 so if you're not
feeling good there's other things that
we can do there's a condition and
there's something that you want to work
out with the person you love but that's
nothing to be ashamed of yeah so in that
relationship part of my life we're still
very much working on it because a lot of
this is more within myself luckily I
have found amazing people who talk about
these conditions openly they help remind
me that I'm not alone and to keep a
healthy perspective and the condition
doesn't have to define my sexuality
or me this could be a really fun
opportunity for you to be able to
explore anything and try to think it
doesn't here it doesn't have ya get me I
get real weird little wait finally okay
yeah all right you have to wait one
minute start soak in completely no you
out you wait for 20 minutes is ideal to
face the window know that your roommate
doesn't get a show right but everyone
else does somebody else yeah even the
Christmas tree it's like oh my god
[Music]